minister
Mr President dear followed him here a
warm welcome to you and your delegation
welcome to the Netherlands Welcome to My
Hometown The Hague
and let me say it is a truly special
moment for us all to have you in our
midst
prime minister the Alexander welcome to
you as well your presence here today is
proof that Belgium and the Netherlands
stand short to shoulder is Ukraine as
friends but also as allies
Vladimir it has been now
434 days since you spoke a few simple
words that resonated all over the world
and I
say what you were saying then
we are all here defending our
independence our country
and it will stay this way
that's what you said
and it will be an understatement to say
that you've kept your word
the resolve and courage of the brave
soldiers and citizens of Ukraine is
without precedent In Our Lifetime
and you yourself have become a symbol or
for the country and its people can do
when they are fighting for their
existence their freedom and their future
and we all admire you for that
when I had the privilege to address the
members of the rabba almost a year ago
and said
we will stay with you every inch of the
way
and let me assure you for vlodimir that
we too are determined to keep our word
because this is an unjust war against
everything we stand for
this is a war against Freedom democracy
and the rule of law in our part of the
world
that's why we stand with Ukrainian
people and why you can count on our
unraveling support
Russia cannot win this war and it must
be held accountable for all the crimes
of aggression and the Injustice that is
inflicting on the people of Ukraine day
after day in this horrific world
so what better place to meet than here
in The Hague the legal capital of the
world
ever since the Downy or flight mh-17 we
in the Netherlands have known that
Justice doesn't come automatically you
have to have staying power
the Netherlands will do everything it
can to ensure that Justice is done for
Ukraine however long it takes and
however difficult it may be
as you know you're a visit to the
Netherlands couldn't have come at a more
symbolic moment
every year on the 4th of may we remember
the Dutch victims of the second world
war and all the soldiers who have given
their life since then for Peace and
Freedom worldwide
tomorrow on the 5th of May Liberation
day we are fortunate that we can
celebrate that we have been a free
country since 1945.
and so after so many years
easy to take Peace and Freedom for
granted
but every day
the brutal Russian aggression against
Ukraine reminds us that the rule of law
is not a given
it needs protecting when threatened and
defending when attacked
so believe me when I say that Ukraine
will remain in our hearts and our minds
not only today and tomorrow
but every day until Peace and Freedom
are restored in your country
this morning you visited the
international criminal court here in The
Hague
later this afternoon we will visit a
location where Dutch military equipment
is dispatched to the battlefield in
Ukraine
your visit to the Netherlands sends get
another strong signal that the people of
Ukraine and its president president will
not give in to Russian aggression and
that the Netherlands and its allies will
continue to support you
every inch of the way
thank you
thanks so much dear prime minister Mark
dear prime minister Alexander dear
journalist dear guess first of all I
want to thank you for invitation Mark to
visit the Netherlands on this very
special day when the memory of all those
whose lives were claimed by Wars is
commemorative and my appreciation will
be gone for me to be here this is a
special invitation and special special
honor we share the pain of these losses
and must put an end to any aggression
and we're meeting here in the cake to
bring peace closer and to restore
Justice what we need we need Justice and
I'm grateful to you Mark again and to
and to the kingdom of the Netherlands
for your powerful and Timeless support
uh of our defense the Patriot and other
weapons that the Netherlands provided us
have already saved thousands thousands
of Ukrainian lives thank you
I'm grateful uh to you Alexander and to
the kingdom of Belgium for the sundarthy
in defense of our common values which
makes Europe
a Europe and thank you for your support
of sanctions against Russia and eight
packages for our country and people
today we focused mainly on security
issues the most important thing now is
to deliver what what was promised to our
soldiers as quickly as possible and I
have called on our partners both the
Netherlands and Belgium to help us to
help us implement the agreements on
Military assistance as quickly as
possible very important that we are
working to create a coalition of armed
vehicles to complement the existing
Coalition of tanks and we hope that the
Netherlands and Belgium together with a
Nordic countries and all our other
partners will effectively support our
initiative degree to create this
Coalition of armed Vehicles besides it's
a time to make positive decisions for
Ukraine on Modern aircrafts and there is
no rational
a reason to postpone such decisions to
train our pilots and to strengthen the
wings for Ukraine a means to speed up
the peace we all wanted of course we we
discussed today a strengthening of our
Common Era we will we will discuss today
very important issue uh our common
theorem
Atlantic security and it's very
important the factory Ukraine has
already become a part of nitu we
cooperate we trust each other and
together we truly make Europe stronger
and so it stands to reason that Ukraine
should become part of Alliance the urine
the so they thought need to Country the
algorithm of think of actions in this
regard can and should be approved by
political decisions at the villainous
Summit of the alliance this summer and
we count on the support of our partners
later we will discuss uh Ukraine EU
relations and we're waiting for a
positive assessment form of progress in
implementing recommendation of the
European commission and we do all our
best during the war we do all reforms
what we have to do and this will be the
time when political called positive
momentum will open the way to a new and
long-classing positive history both for
Ukraine and for the whole Europe and one
more point I would like to thank
you for your support our peace formula
is 10 very points that can restore not
only our territorial integrity and
security but also can reliably guarantee
the long-term security of Europe and the
world this is our joint task to restore
the full force of the U.N Charter and
international lore in general everything
that was violated by Putin and Russia
peace calls for sanctions to be stronger
for the isolation of Russia to be more
complete peace calls for assets of
terrorist state to be confiscated and
peace cause damages to be repaired and
ruins to be rebuilt and I'm sure we will
do it do it together thanks again to you
Mark and thank you Alexander
[Music]
thank you for the an invitation and an
invitation that is symbolic on many
levels first of all on the ties that we
have as countries ties which in essence
are about values values of democracy of
respect of sovereignty
but also symbolic on the timing you
invite us here on the eve of the Dutch
Liberation day where we commemorate how
our British friends our American friends
Canadians and so many others came here
to liberate us and and to bring peace as
you stated it very well I think as a
moment of this it is important to
continue to show our solidarity with
Eucharist as we have done both countries
and so many others from from day one
even before the The Invasion and let me
be clear on that we will continue
with the same motivation and the same
engagement
to continue to show our solidarity with
Ukraine it is now our help to our turn
to help Ukraine to get rid once again of
a cruel and an illegal occupation kind
of occupation that our countries have
endured during the second world war as
well this is why Belgium is in the
process of preparing a new package of
military aid for uh for Ukraine and and
as we know in these military aid
packages there are often practical
obstacles but I can tell you that there
is not a single doubt in any of the
Belgian hearts and Minds that we need to
continue to support Ukraine
that is why last March Belgium seized
approximately 200 million euros of the
proceeds from Russian assets that were
frozen in Belgium and we are using those
funds exclusively to help the Ukrainian
war effort and to support Ukrainian
refugees in Belgium and I'm convinced
that we can go further in that domain
not only by seizing the interests but
also looking at the full proceeds of the
Russian assets themselves since the
beginning of the war
uh Belgian Belgian Services have seized
more than 180 billion of Russian assets
of the Russian Central Bank
we are now examining how we can fully
use the proceeds of those Russian assets
to support the Ukrainian war effort and
to support the Reconstruction of Ukraine
as well and Belgium is ready to play a
leading role in that and we will do that
together with the European commission
I've always said since the beginning of
this war we need to hit Russia in a
Smart Way in an effective way using
Russian money to rebuild a country that
they are destroying makes perfect sense
it makes perfect sense from economic
perspective but even more so it makes
perfect sense from a moral perspective
as well so dear mark thank you for
extending this this invitation here here
today in in The Hague and their Vladimir
we cannot repeat it often enough how
much we admire your courage how we
admire the courage of your population
and let it be clear again we will
continue to support you with everything
we can support
I think it looks on it
first question is for one plus one TV
channel
president
yeah just just a second
question
is foreign
is
foreign
[Music]
next question anyways
a president
foreign
minister today or are you hoping to get
them later today and it's also a
question to our prime minister on which
of these four points can you assure Mr
zelenski that yes indeed Ukraine can
count on this unwavering support because
it's not a secret that for instance
Netherlands is very hesitant very
reluctant if it comes to giving the
accession to your country of NATO and
that's why I was wondering if uh at some
point if Netherlands keeps on being
hesitant or reluctant even will you cope
stop calling our prime minister
so uh
a lot of different challenges
and a lot of difficulties you know on
the battle of the earth I I'm like the
president of the country which is in war
I'm of course
we need a lot of different issues to
have a victory and it not depends only
on us and of course we need Justice and
it's not depends only on our
possibilities and our wishes that's why
we need
dear friends
and uh really and but first of all we
need because we fight for for common
values and I feel support of ours as of
support of of parliament it's a board of
Marx support of government since first
days of full-scale War it's really true
and I'm thankful for it and like I said
patrons
Etc but but can I now focus on that
things what we discussed we we are
speaking now about what's going on on
the battlefield
and what we are preparing for
we are preparing for real Justice
but there are two directions of justice
justice on the battlefield we have
to decorate our territory we have all
these rights we're not fighting with
Russia on Russian character we are
fighting against not with against their
aggression and that's why we have to do
it and I'm focusing now on this and we
spoke about it how to help how to
strengthen Ukraine and our army and to
be strong
we are not weak we want just to be
stronger
and that's why we need this support and
I think we will get it
we speak about very contradict things
about very Contracting number of things
I I can't share I mean this with you all
this pancreatic issues Maybe
somebody I mean there's no because we
when you are preparing such details you
know such things such steps forward
counter-offensive steps which are very
important I I don't want to speak a lot
of you know with details
yeah so
but
I think that we will get this support
and it's it's about weapon and if we're
speaking about NATO
we need and I think we
last some months is we have got
positive messages
from some countries
who already support Ukraine rarely
support and to do something more than
Open Door on villainous Summit we need
something more yes and I think that's
also
our friends will support us and will see
us our in Native but anyway we are we're
realistic we know that we will not be in
need during the war
but
during the war we want to get very clear
message that we will be in need after
the war
let's listen Mark
three issues f-16s NATO and E what was
the fourth one
of course as you know a line item seven
out of the zelinski 10 point piece plan
is the line item you're very much
focusing on of course on all the line
items but particularly 0.7 which is
about accountability
uh and uh the Hague being the
international capital of Justice it's
clear that we want to work on this I'm
not Trump you know we're also working on
this horrible issue of the Abduction of
children together with Germany and other
countries in Belgium we are working on
collecting all the evidence of what has
happened what is happening currently in
Ukraine including with fact training
missions to make sure that all the
evidence is captured working closely
with the ICC so on that issue we are in
a complete agreement on the f-16s uh
notabus we are working intensely with
our partners Belgium others the UK
Denmark on getting that debates somehow
to a conclusion we are not there yet
and that's always very sensitive I've
seen this before with Leo Parts too I've
seen it before with the Panzer how it
says it takes time to bring that to a
conclusion but at this moment the Panzer
howitzers are in Ukraine the Leo twos
are being delivered to Ukraine so we
will work on this diligently on the
f-16s and clearly the support in
Parliament for this government to work
on that on NATO uh very sensitive
exactly for the reason the president was
mentioning which is that at this moment
there is a war going on in Ukraine this
terrible Russian aggression War and here
I think that Jen stoltenberg the nature
Secretary General found some very
practical wording saying that Ukraine
belongs to your Atlantic family but he
also said that Ukraine will eventually
become a member of NATO and that he must
continue to support Ukraine to make this
possible uh and also for the Netherlands
it's clear that we support Ukraine's
NATO Ambitions what we are working on
now in a run-up to the field news Summit
is to make sure that we take a step that
we do not just go back to the wording
from Bucharest and whatever but that we
take a clear step and what exactly will
be will be negotiated over the next four
to six weeks we have to do that with all
the 30 NATO countries to make sure that
everybody is on one line and
on EU accession as you know thanks to
the statesmanship of originality we were
able last May to come to conclusions
which is that
that's that your membership and the
future your membership for Ukraine is
now clearly on the table and that the
negotiations are going on and I think we
can still thank her for that because it
was a difficult issue not just for the
Netherlands but also with many other
countries in this part of the world
because we had our doubts at that moment
but I am absolutely impressed by what
the president's team is doing fighting a
war against Russia and at the same time
making concrete steps in terms of
clearing the way in terms of this whole
process towards EU accession is up to
the commission later this year to assess
the progress there's a clear process
within the EU there's different from
NATO there's not a clear process in NATO
that step by step this is what you need
to do to get to accessions in the EU we
have that process the next step is for
the EU commission to come up with a
report in October but I'm really
impressed in my last visit in February
to Kiev but also last year July before
to see what they are doing in the middle
of this war to to clear that path to
this ambition and that gives me every
confidence that he can get there but
again it's not now to the commission to
assess in October the progress on
Ukraine also Moldova and of course the
Western Balkan countries
paytm
um
thank you Mr President it's wonderful to
see you in good health here in the
Netherlands our question is how
seriously do you take the Russian
outspoken threat now that they think is
Justified to eliminate whether in
Ukraine right here in The Hague
thank you
any decisions of Russia an audience
received for us for today any decisions
of their leader
still 20 from 24th of February he's not
leader of
for us he's not he's not there the real
leader of the country in which words or
steps
you can I mean you can trust yes so for
me it doesn't matter what what they
think we know what they what they do we
see their demotivated country
on the battlefield
what is very important we don't see ever
the strong Army on the battlefield and a
really strong
society which supports their their steps
forward we see a different uh radical
groups which are supported which want to
use some nuclear which are called what
to you know to burn all our country
that's it for us it's it's not more any
any you know uh and
so I mean that's
it's not interesting interesting topic
we we will not negotiate with these kind
of persons anything
I think that they have to think to how
to change the climate in their country
to change their regime
and after that they can bring their
society to any diplomatic
a possibility yes to finish to finish
this war but first what what we see we
have to the occupate our country we all
just in our borders
question you preform news
I will switch to Ukrainian president is
Academy
um
China
it's a training missions
foreign
we we don't think that we will don't
have success is not our way and that is
why I can't answer to your question I I
have only one Target and we understand
it and uh so I think we will have
results I I can't say that that is
totally success because you know
never knows and when you lose people
it's not the right word success when you
lose people even you if you win you lose
even you win in some sector in some
territory even when you do occupied and
everybody who need it needed in Ukraine
it's really but you lose also because
you lose people
and this losses are very painful for for
Country yeah yes it's a bit it's big
threats anyway
we will go we are waiting something from
our partners because of different
reasons absolutely different reasons and
during this war I'm it's not very simple
for me to come to to other countries to
our partners yes because I want don't
want to demotivate our people our
society and our soldiers and I can't go
you know everywhere when I when I you
know should go or want yes I mean that
so you have to understand why
why I'm sometimes somewhere
and because of preparation really
because of stressing to be more strong
on the battlefield
to bring some not good news for Russians
yesterday I was in Finland
not far from
Justice
thank you so much thank you last
questions
thank you very much
very important question
of course we want to use all the money
because they destroyed it you know you
know they destroyed our
energy Network or schools educational
Network I mean this school's
universities Dr Alexandra's museums
charges and the infrastructure yeah just
infrastructure for for for people and of
course for all of this uh issues we need
money and we spoke about it today and
the Alexander told me that they are
filing some mechanism to to help us in
this in renovation I think that that is
the the problem and the question not
only of Belgium I think that the problem
with the law in in the countries who
really have this
this morning Frozen some money
it's not enough
if you're asking is enough it's it's not
enough because even even a world bank I
think that the last analogy issues us
that that now we we need more than 400
billions is real statistics but we don't
know whether we don't know what's going
on on temporary temporary occupied
territories I mean that one what is the
level of destroying there so we are
finding the mechanisms we are asking our
friends to help us and to find these
mechanism
in countries and of course on on the
level of EU on a level of
euh
thank you for the uh for the question as
I as I said I think first of all from
from moral perspective it's totally
defendable uh
creating such a dramatic situations
the proceeds of the almost 200 billion
which are which are Frozen in in Belgium
of course that can only happen when
there is a legal basis
respect for the rule of law is an
essential value of what we are what we
share and and Belgium will be taking the
lead together with European commission
uh to to to create a legal framework to
make that seizure of the proceeds
possible on top of that the question is
is there other ways you could use the
capital
to make sure that the financing is
available for the Reconstruction of
Ukraine and to finance the war uh to our
to our efforts and that as well we are
exploring of what possibilities would be
but of course it needs to be on a legal
on a legal framework but this is
something that we are working on with
our specialists
thank you so much
It's the final one
um
today I was in Parliament and Parliament
oh my
second uh invitation the first one was
online and today I I came I came just
with great honor and I'm honored to be
invited by Mark and by them and
I said a lot of
One Things We Shall which are going from
from heart of all our ukrainians we are
thankful for transferring on a
battlefield for refugees refugees just
for people
and it's
the president of parliament he said to
me that
he has
you know special attitude to our people
to Ukrainian that they really are lost
to to to be in Holland and I said it
makes for us we are very sample but it
makes problems because after the war we
need them to get back
anyway and I said of course of course
this day is very important
history
and I'm proud that I'm
I've been invited these days and
of course we wish of course we wish
pierce your your country and and of
course it's a beauty that this tragedy
today will remember victims who have
been during the second World War
all our countries know it
and we know this tragedy and all our all
all the countries in Europe not only in
Europe United States
Etc
know what's uh regime of Hitler's regime
brought to Europe only
blood and victims and
that's but it's a big tragedy is that
today
we again fight him with the with the
regime
and of course we are calling and we give
messages to different parliaments and
leaders
not to repeat not to give possibility or
regime of Russia to bring and to involve
all us to the sword World War not to
give him possibility now where we are
staying and now we're staying and we are
fighting
against it
and against possibility
to involve all the walls to a new
treasure there big tragedy and that's
why we need help and I I've got this
this support from Parliament thank you
so much for your attention thank you
foreign